what's that believe nation welcome to
another YouTube hangout I'm excited to
be here with my friend the CEO of sage
the accounting software that I use to
power my business mr. Stephen Kelly
welcome back sir
greta cm in bread be on the broadcast
today and i think it's gonna be a real
kind of roller coaster of only 30
minutes Evan but it's such a great topic
for any entrepreneur yeah we've got a
we've got a tight timeline today Stephen
is taking off and I had some scheduling
issues too so we're here at 10:30 new
time now before we get started it's
everybody's favorite time of day
Stephen Kelly's gonna give us some
quotes around carpe diem how you can
seize the day what do you got for us to
even hey I loved Evan and we use this
phrase through all those language
scholars out there is a bit of Latin it
means seize the day
carpe diem and you guys loved it so much
from fed back to Evan though we made the
whole session about this social cause to
kick off with some fantastically famous
people couple of them first of all
Gandhi and this is really good the
future depends on what you do today and
the second one from Tim Ferriss very
focused on the topic of today focus on
being productive instead of just being
busy and then some Kelly quotes Kerry
quotes to kick ass in three quotes first
of all excuses last forever
opportunities don't second one you are
only confined to the walls that you've
built for yourself and last one carpe
diem seize the day don't let the day
seize you
oh don't like the day sees you I like
that little addition at the end there
that's great I love it every no it's
good really important time because I
think when you start a business is so
important to get focused on what really
moves to da Mousa needle and it's so
easy to get distracted and that's what
we want to help you today
alright so before we get into the
questions guys if you have questions for
me and Stephen put in in a chat you
could tag me it's easy - boy what are
your high-level thoughts for
entrepreneurs around carpe diem seize in
today's difficulties they have like what
advice would you give someone who's
having
struggle but having a struggle all
season their day yeah I think gum ever
knew no this is when you're an
entrepreneur you always want to try and
keep time as your friend
and when time becomes your enemy you
chase your tail and a great quote from
Yuri is I know looking the way you
organize yourself are you routine you're
structure it's really important to get
that cadence of success and you only I
think do your external facing activity
on a Thursday - I have solar he kind of
that one day to focus and that's so
important you know there's loads of
quotes from great people we admire like
Sheryl Sandberg she kind of uses a
spiral notebook to the tasks that she
hasn't listened and then rips it out
when she's done and completed her to-do
list for the day bezels you know the
two-piece are all kind of the guys
started Amazon you know business genius
only only ever invite enough people to
feed two pizzas because otherwise you
kind of get meeting madness
Elon Musk another one great one he every
morning gets up really early filters he
emails into the first half hour to
prioritize what he's going to do and how
he's going to spend the day so I think
every successful entrepreneur I've met
Evan is is ruthless about how they use
their time and what they focus their
time on to deliver the outcomes they
need to be successful so how do you what
advice do you have for people to
prioritize your time I think kind of the
first thing would be is to think about
you know you've got a big idea
you've got a vision you've got an
ambition but then you kind of break it
so you know how do you skin and eat an
elephant you break it down in small
chunks so then you say what do I need to
achieve within 90 days what a success
look like then you kind of work back
with 60 days 30 days and you can kind of
working backwards right to today so what
do I need to do today and to have
achieved to either got my product
launched or whatever it is or got a
partner established or you know starting
the blab or whatever it is that you need
to do what's the deliverable that will
help you on your business journey and
that's the most critical thing I think
great entrepreneurs I mean you know it's
tough to do sometimes they almost live
in the future and they look at
themselves back to there and say on that
day I did this and they use the past
tense and I
talked about the sort of end result
planning they do live in the future and
work backwards to say what is it I need
to achieve what is the outcome I need to
achieve I think all of us get consumed
by inputs where's the money
do I need more people all these inputs
but if you actually go straight to what
is the outcome
what is the deliver what do I need to
have done by the end of this month what
do I need to adapt by the end of July to
have sold you know X units or to have
established my website or to have signed
up to partners with a plan where they
can be successful so it's kind of that
end result is the outcomes and then work
backwards to say well what does that
mean I need to do today what do I need
wine when I kind of lie down I've done
my last bit of running and the exercise
before I go to bed and I walk the dog
Evan what all I need to have kind of
nailed today and it's almost like that
that kind of diligence and sometimes you
smash the ball out of the path sometimes
you think actually I didn't do that
today and then next morning you say well
how important is it going to get me to
my mission and is it going to get me to
the business plan that I set out for
myself I love it
well we're tight on time guys so let's
get to some questions rapid-fire
hopefully we can answer as many as
possible for you
first up Salima who's writing in Stephen
how do you prevent overwhelm from
information overload and make sure you
spend enough time on profit producing
activities that's a great question
Salima I think dumb kind of key things
is a great skill for an entrepreneur is
to ask these sort of rhetorical
questions of yourself so you know what
what is the value of my time what is the
value of what is what is my objective
what am I trying to achieve what a
success look like all those sort of
questions and and how do I set myself a
target that's measurable for you know
today ultimately so you really then
invest my time almost like it's almost
like being on - no I've never kind of
followed this amount ever but it's like
being in a movie the movie is called
your story it's the you know move for me
it's the same story the year is the Evan
Carmichael believe and if you kind of
break the movie down into all the frames
you want to be thinking today's frame
this is what I need to achieve
so that frame is I know the movies I'm
the director and therefore you know to
your question Salima is being super
focused to make sure the activity you're
doing today really drives our
profitability success and that starts
with your customers I love it
Corey Brown is saying Steven I'm
planning on donating a large portion of
my profits of my business to fund my
charity what is a good percentage I'd
like to go 5050 or more is that feasible
I think Corey what I'll advise you to do
is with all these sort of things
actually with a business kind of start
small think big and then seize the
moment seize a day you might want to say
because you need kind of some growth
capital and you want to fund that
through yourselves Evans got the
greatest quote on this I'll pass a broom
in a minute you know you kind of don't
want to borrow money you want to run
your business through yourselves with
your customers right at the heart of it
I would say probably in terms of I
admire and salute you in terms of the
charitable compassionate capitalism that
obviously fuels you and will be the
heart of your business the beating heart
but I'd say in the early maybe first
year conserve as much of the cash to
fund the growth of the business and then
have an aspiration year to so you said
50 percent I'd say maybe within three
years three to five years maybe it's 50%
but I'd say for the first year maybe
it's just 5% maybe the second year you
ramped it up to 15 to 20 percent and
then you kind of feel more investment
into the charities you support now
obviously it'd be really cool if your
business idea was associated with the
charity because then it's very holistic
and it's very integrated ever your
thoughts yeah well I'm just thinking
about the Sage Foundation because you're
doing so much work with the Sage
Foundation huh I mean it may not be a
fair comparison given the size of Sage
first startup but how do you decide how
much budget to give sage and the Sage
Foundation on an annual basis yeah we
are worth it so great we've got a model
that we talked about called 2 plus 2
plus 2 so we give 2 percent of our
colleagues time so we've got 14 thousand
folks around the world that's 5 days a
year paid volunteering in the
communities of Atlanta Georgia out in
Southern California right across
aperture on toe
Vancouver so that's for to sell at
70,000 days pay volunteering bias which
is a massive investment in the community
and then in addition to that the second
part of the two is two percent of free
cash flows so we we tend to look at of
it as it's kind of not percentage of
revenues but a percentage of cash flows
and the sort of SR proxy in terms of
profitability as well obviously and then
the other bit is we give to free
products into the charitable sector so
any not-for-profit any charity as long
as it's not so politically associated
with affiliated and stuff like that then
they get kind of help return to get
their own business right so they can run
their business and any donations they
get they can be super efficiency to make
sure they go to the causes rather than
kind of run their back office an
administration so it's kind of two plus
two plus two so we started with the
philosophy it would be company but it's
two percent of free cash flows and that
makes a meaningful contribution so you
know to the opposite of the you can
notice like sixty major grants given out
to charities through the course of last
year and it's a great way actually Cori
to connect to the people you hire to
your mission and you'll find that if you
really talk to that mission you'll find
it a great recruitment tool for
fantastic people and a brilliant
retention tool as well Evan your
thoughts what what I love about that
that I think Cora can learn from is at
the beginning of a business it's very
rare to be massively profitable and so
none of your targets aren't you tied the
profit that the revenue like cash flow
is one a guess but the other ones are
product in kind and in time where
someone who wants to give back like
Corey might feel like he's not doing
enough at the beginning cuz he's not
making enough profit but of core if you
think about hey how can I spend you know
a day a month volunteering my time or do
you have products or services that you
could donate in-kind may help fill your
soul while you're not able to make a lot
of profits yet because you need to
reinvest back into your business so I
love I love that specific example and I
think entrepreneurs can leverage it as
well whether the numbers are are the
same or not only time it's the profit
may be limiting because you may not make
profit for the first three years like as
you're building your come
yeah actually everyone on that you tend
to find you know this when you go out to
work with charities you tend to find
they're really struggling for really
competent capable people in who've got a
lot of business kind of operational
experience so Cory if you if you've kind
of got operational entrepreneurial
experience your time will be hugely
valuable to charities ah and you
shouldn't underestimate that and he even
if we gave them a day a month and you
kind of work with a chief executive for
charity the impact you'd have with
mentoring them which you know really
coaching them would be immense so that
that could be your biggest contribution
and instead of giving cash when you
really want to preserve that cash to
fund your growth yeah cool guys lots of
questions coming in if you tag me it's a
lot easier for me to see them mix is
reading in evidence even I feel I feel
like I am too far in the future I'm
trying to order expensive custom parts
before I have orders or can make one in
my garage how can I roll how can I roll
my spending habits back I know that hey
what's your great quote about raising
money and stuff like that I don't know
making money making money oh I hate
spending money til I make you money I
guess I mixed two down to this I think
there's a few things I've learned
through startup business myself it's
always great to start with the customer
and actually go and pitch the idea to
the customer and then almost almost
build the product almost like
just-in-time in an agile way and then
obviously you can defer the costs
associated with customers and in and
I've done it a few businesses where you
actually get the customer commitment you
you're very honest with the customer in
terms of the lead cycle are the delivery
cycle but basically you get the
customers to fund the product build
second thing is you know great phrase
I've always learned and hold myself even
in this company say guys tell everybody
to treat the company's money as if it's
our own and to you know every dollar
every cent you spend to actually make
sure you get a return that and the other
did the other phrase you can do this
for now I used the word spend there and
I say we should eradicate that from our
language because language is quite
important and if you use the word spend
the second word that comes into your
mind may be waste whereas if you use the
word invest the second word that comes
into your mind is return so everything
you invest every dollar you have you
think ruthlessly what is a return on
that but my general kind of really kind
of seize the moment in that theme is go
and recruit your customers win the
customers and then get them to fund the
product build and then you can scale it
up and you can manage your cash flow to
support the growth yeah I'm 100% on
board
go get the client find someone with the
need go get the client get the sale have
them help you find it
the meat Demetrius is writing in
evidence even in a declining economy in
high taxes like Greece what do you
suggest stay here on struggle and maybe
be successful or move out and start anew
toss the grass coy question you know
Evan you've been over to Europe we've
been down at Greece we love Greece loads
of colleagues that to work for us a
Greek and obviously the economy that's
been tough there they've had a lot of
issues associated with kind of the
financial deficit and is I think the
unemployment rate have and I think it's
like for young people it's like 25
percent or something horrible so um now
that I'd say to me just come back if
you've got an idea the good news about
social media about kind of e-commerce
about the world the world is a global
village so you could set up a really
successful business from Greece now why
would you do that
you've probably got loads of people you
could recruit there you've probably got
people are really willing to work and
give you a commitment where they come
into work and they give you their best
time and actually you could probably pay
them through a little bit of equity and
actually preserve the cash in terms of
paying them wages and stuff like that so
you could really get their commitment
energy passion and you've probably got a
Labour Paul that's you know if you go to
places like Canada in the u.s. the
economies are full employment you try a
harpy
Toronto you try and hire people in
Seattle wow it's really hard to get the
right skills for you see the good news
is the great great Greek education
system you know again Greeks have gone
all over the world Australia Canada
everywhere they travel fantastically
they got great international
multicultural skills so you might have
all the things on your doorstep in
Greece to make your shoes you're
successful in that economy now if that's
not if you haven't got a product idea
that is scalable from Greece and it's
almost like a service society that's
depending on you obviously you've got to
go where the customers and where the
market is so that means you go to
Toronto New York London wherever it may
be and you could then so you are the
product you are the service is your
consultant that's gonna be kind of
making a difference so I guess it
depends the answer question directly
depends what your big idea is if it's
very human capital dependent and you you
need to go where the customer is if it's
actually a product idea you've probably
got some great capability from Greece to
launch an online you could build a
social media presence from Greece as
well as anywhere else in the world you
guys before brand so you could do that
but it very much depends on what your
idea is what do you think Evan yeah one
you know I don't like it when people are
blaming their circumstances I think it's
it's always like you could say well in
London it's impossible to start a
business because it's just too expensive
to start a business and I can't find it
it's just there's always a reason why
you can't win in your market always and
there's always reason why you can win
and so focusing on what you can do with
what you do have like that's that is the
essence of what entrepreneurs do you
don't look at the problems you look at
the opportunities so there's anybody
who's ever looked like you who's gone on
in one you know you can too there's tons
of entrepreneurs who've won staying in
Greece and leaving Greece like you can
do it
and so I just I think I think as a
starting point it's not a great mindset
like I would honestly rather come on and
ask a question about how to grow this
business as opposed to blaming the
circumstances so I think you could win
I think the economy's getting more
global I think it's easier to sell
international than ever before and I
think there's a lot of advantages to
being in Greece I would spend time on
growing the business instead of thinking
about the circumstances your own
yeah and if I actually if you've got a
very specific like Greek dependent
product there's massive obviously if you
got to have a Melbourne there's a huge
Greek population a community there and
they still speak Greek language you know
so so you just look wider than the
shores of Greece and the beautiful
Mediterranean lapping up on the beach
and you see a kind of world out there
where there's you know I'd totally
agreed to meet Russ you've got great
opportunities if you've got the
resourceful us and the energy and the
passion idea you go focus solely on the
opportunity because it because it could
be great for you I just think there's so
few businesses that that you actually
have to leave Greece to be successful in
I think I think ninety-nine point eight
percent of businesses you could run
successfully from Greece as long as you
adopt a mindset that I can win in Greece
actually I've been on that I I kind of
said that if it's all about you and
you're the product and it's a services
business kind of consultant then you
might want to go in the market is the
market will come to you as well through
you know social media through this sort
of you know we're four thousand miles
away from each other we can have a great
conversation here you can offer
brilliant consultant services I know
loads of product companies who started
in the US and implemented by Skype down
in Australia you know with no one give a
a plane ticket with dealt or anyone like
that they've just kind of got on skype
from they sold sold themselves and so I
think the power of what technologies are
done it definitely people talk about
this global village but it's so true
it's so on show time for that yeah and I
honestly group that questioning with a
bunch of other limiting questions like I
didn't go to school or I didn't I don't
have the connections I don't have the
parents I don't have you know whatever
blaming the circumstances instead of
just going off and doing the thing but
you're right you're today Evan you're
hardcore come on guys don't waste time
let's go carpe diem let's do it carpe
diem is not blaming your circumstances
season the day that's it
Corey's saying thank you gentlemen I
appreciate you taking time so much to
help
Rosie is asking do you have an exit
strategy in terms for your future for
your business life to do other things
you want to do and if so what's on the
bucket list great so um I've got kind of
two questions arrows is one is Jeff an
exit strategy I guess for your business
secondly kind of work-life balance and
what's on your bucket list so I would
say day one just think they weren't
thinking every day your business you
know you read about they won't thinking
I think it's really refreshing because
it challenges to you but I would never a
day one have an exit strategy I think
about how do I grow how do I grow how do
i scale how do I believe because the
more you do that and the more energy you
put into that the more inbound calls you
will have for people who want to buy
your business
the more attractive businesses the more
sustainable is the more high-quality
customers and that more you can scale
your business honestly you'll be
overwhelmed with the number of people
who want to build a business and buy
your business so I wouldn't ever think
about how do I build a you know how to
have a baby to create to be the most
beautiful paper to get it sold
no I would think about how do I grow my
business how do i scale it how do I keep
my customers happy do the right things
to your business and then the office
will come in secondly in terms of a
bucket list and work-life balance I
think we all do you know and I think the
thing I relish is probably the day I
retire will be you know sadly the day I
die cuz I just like work but you know I
I probably won't work at the intensity
for me personally forever
we love to balance stuff so I know Evan
loves to go running he does the dog walk
I love to do exercise I like to travel I
love to be with my family and I try and
carve out enough time to do the things
that are important to me because I think
it's really important for all of us to
have good karma and we're you know
whether you like yoga like meditating
this stuff you like to do ultimately you
know I kind of believe you know one life
is never gonna be enough for any of us
is we've got a hell of a lot to pack in
but there's always things in terms of
traveling bucket lists people are me do
things to do businesses to start that
you want to take off as you go through
life and I think that's admirable so
again form your bucket list could be six
things again in the spirit of carpe diem
be super focused don't have a list of
400 things
just focus all the things that really
matter yeah I don't have an exit
strategy for my business it's always a
reflection of me it's it's evolved and
changed a lot and it will continue to
evolve and change and if I grow tired
with if I grow tired with YouTube I'll
look to sell my YouTube channel and go
off and do something else but there's no
like I'm gonna do YouTube for five years
and then look to sell it that's that's
not part of my game in terms of a bucket
list I don't have a bucket list as soon
as I get an idea for something I really
want to do I just go out and do it
I just find a way to get started you
know like a as soon as I act like in
five years would I want to be I just
start doing it immediately I think if
you know we're gonna be in five years
you're actually thinking small and
cheating yourself so yeah as soon as I
get something on my bucket doesn't mean
I don't have a list of to do is a
hundred percent and we have a list of
two dudes that are way bigger than we
ever have time for like Steven said you
know we want to have 18 different
lifetimes but in terms of like the
bucket list things as soon as again to
my head I just find a way to go out and
do it yeah I think I ever naturally
there's loads of people I know who say
maybe it's a different age thing they
say I've got when I retire I do all
these things I just say if you want to
do these things you prioritize and say
we'll do it now I think you're great on
will always say you know we use this
phrase JD I just do it if you want to do
it just do it make it happen if you
don't just do it then it's obviously not
priority to JD I've never mean I just do
it I learned something new on these
things
I still think like you're speaking
mythology or what that was great I
haven't seen that come out on your
Instagram I'm waiting I'm waiting you
are you are having your courage and
that's all I love it was great Haley is
right in to say Steven what are your
thoughts on single pointed focus versus
having multiple passions and pursuits in
your business
that's a great question Haley I think
there's a couple of data points I can
give you here as well actually interest
enough multitasking there's a lot of
research on this reduces productivity by
40% ah
so focusing on one task at a time
typically makes you much way more
productive
and achieve much more in terms your
outcomes the other thing I think Haley
is to Evans point is there's an argument
to say you want to try a couple of
things but they've got to be related
because when you start your business
over time your business evolves based on
what your customers are telling you what
the market needs are you know in this
world like social media who would have
guessed five years ago that we'd be here
on this channel and the year's time
there might be a new channel it
completely takes over the power of
Instagram all these things change so you
don't want to be kind of fixed or have
your head in the sand like an ostrich
but what I would absolutely advocate is
kind of stick to the core principle the
core theme the essence of what you
believe in what your idea is
and then around it kind of do the course
correction to be successful to grow and
go where the market is so I'll advocate
kind of focuses everything and that that
should be you know I use a phrase like
we don't want to be all things to all
people and you can't be pigs one thing
you want to be really successful at and
go after that what do you think ever I
would just quickly say think about and
instead of war combine them so whatever
your multiple interests are how do you
make how do you not have two or three or
four separate businesses but how do you
combine them into one that's how you're
going to stand out and be unique so if
you love writing and you love swimming
you know be the writer for the swimming
industry like combine the end up those
things into one business instead of
doing separate ones so that that's
that's how you're gonna win it so you're
gonna send out you might notice Evan
walls to talk so great guy with a family
so you look at the YouTube channel and
stuff at the family loves salsa dancing
stuff about salsa dancer always always
land and he's got rhythm he's got really
you can see now the salsa dance is just
taking off please sleep there he's
getting rhythm I'm also I'm also my
trampoline so I bounce all day long
people saying thank you for the answers
great interview appreciate that Rosie
Sam is writing maybe quick last
questions we gotta we gotta run same as
writing Steven how do you pick a
business / startup idea and just start
oh I just think Sam
just do it just pay
you can do something you're passionate
about something you dream about
something where there's a pain point
you've noticed that would be scalable
and then that's your business idea and
then that's the the area where you've
got a gap to feel and then think about
where's the customers
test driver with a few friends if you
can't find customers immediately start
opening up your network through social
media
ah and you know you you could become the
thought leader in this space so I but
most of all in the spirit of kind of the
whole theme of today seize the moment
start today
just make it happen I love it Hayley's
writing in the say Stephen thank you for
the answers amazing it's it's half hour
is crazy it we fly through it I think a
flight to catch to get somewhere final
message Stephen what do you want to
carpe diem how do you want to close this
off for a belief nation okay so a couple
of things quote from a customers
actually a private yacht charters out in
Washington so there Kenneth who kind of
runs businesses write down what you want
to achieve by what day and then work
backwards today and say what does that I
need to do shape their to get it done
and then seize the moment
and I think that's the essence I mean
all the great entrepreneurs I know yeah
they're dreamers and they got big dreams
but boy do they execute the speed of
light and they seize every day and they
seize every hour and they make the most
of it to ultimately achieve their dreams
and that's what we want you guys to do
so most of all always do it and have fun
doing it because there's nothing more
noble than the the cause of an
entrepreneur well believe I love it well
we're getting great feedback you guys
are rocking it thank you for your answer
very important to me you changed my life
god bless you all right well thank you
guys so much for the love we will be
back again next month I appreciate the
support Stephen thank you so much for
making time for this to happen cuz I
know your agenda super tight today
we appreciate you thank you guys for
watching continue to believe and
whatever your one word is and we'll see
always believe Evan we love the rock and
it's a great broadcast great to be part
of it